ok freunde ich habe ein video im
internet gefunden namens dieses video
lässt sich deinen namen vergessen hab
mich natürlich ein bisschen stutzig und
habe mich gefragt hey was hat es damit
auf sich und es ist ein video in dem
einen verschiedene so etwas wird einem
da vorgespielt auf jeden fall habe ich
mir davon drei verschiedene videos
rausgesucht und wir schauen uns das
jetzt zusammen an und gucken ob wir
danach noch unseren namen kennen ich bin
bei der ganzen sache ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen skeptisch
ich habe so ein ähnliches video schon
mal hoben ein gott okay die farbe
verändert sich gerade ich habe so ein
ähnliches video schon mal vor circa
einem jahr hochgeladen und da habe ich
zwischendurch trotzdem noch schnitte
gesetzt also so richtig wie ich um mein
gott jetzt ist sie schon wieder
irgendwas anders ich habe in diesem
video dennoch irgendwie zwischendurch an
die face cameron gesucht hat so ein
bisschen spiel reinziehen gemacht und so
weiter und so fort auch diesmal werde
ich nur die musik stoppen lassen und
werde wirklich die ganze zeit in die
mitte vom screenshot und die fans kamen
gleich groß lassen so dass ihr einfach
mehr die möglichkeit habt das ganze hier
live mit mir zu machen
also schaut am besten wie gesagt mein
gott
auch jetzt haben wir ein standbild
glaube ich versucht die ganze zeit in
die mitte des screens zuschauen versucht
auch außerdem nicht zu blinzeln außerdem
müsste es wirklich ganz dringend tun
aber schaut auf kleinsten auf mich weil
dann ist die illusion wieder weg
versucht wirklich die ganze zeit in die
mitte von dem screen zu schauen
falls wir weggucken sollten
beziehungsweise wenn wir weg gucken
sollten werde ich euch das schon noch
sagen die sind jetzt extra verschiedene
animationen gewählt worden ich weiß ja
dass die augen in einer gewissen form an
dass tricky macht das ganze ist übrigens
auch überhaupt nicht schädlich
falls sie jetzt gerade sorgen haben
solltet einfach in die mitte des screens
schauen natürlich klar wenn man jetzt
irgendwie epilepsie hat oder irgend
einer augenkrankheit oder so dann ist es
wiederum was anderes aber schaut mit mir
auf jeden fall einfach weiter in die
mitte des screens ey leute ich bin ganz
ehrlich
ich fühle mich ein bisschen stromrechner
ich will nicht lügen aber ich fühle mich
gerade schon ein bisschen komisch auf
den beinen ich nehme meine videos jemand
stehen auf deswegen ist es für mich
gerade doppelt schwierig weil ich musste
ja gerade am tisch festhalten ehrlich
gesagt ich habe auch glaube ich ganz
wien im ganze video gefühlt noch nicht
geblinzelt das ist wirklich unfassbar
krass ich schaue einfach in die mitte
das sieht aus als guckt man irgendwie
ein bisschen schlecht ganz ehrlich es
ist ein bisschen so als würde man
joghurt zusammen mit schoko sirup in
mixa packen und dann von oben frontal
nach unten da rein schauen ich bin echt
gespannt wie es gleich sein wird wenn
wir einfach mal uns hier im raum dann
theoretisch umschauen
die sache ist was ich gerade auf
feststelle ich schaue in die mitte aber
ich sehe ab und zu rote sprüche oh mein
gott
oh gott oh mein gott nein
liga ab
das bewegt sich
also das war jetzt das erste der drei
videos die ich ausgesucht habe am kombi
nun allerdings direkt zum zweiten video
wonach wir angeblich unseren namen
vergessen sollten also ich weiß nicht
wie es euch geht aber ich weiß noch
immer dass ich luca heißt das hier ist
eine ganz andere art von video und zwar
nicht irgendwie ein bild was sich im
kreis dreht oder ein punkt der den
radialen filter der oma hat oder
irgendwie so und dann gegen eine
animation abspielt sondern das hier ist
ein bild was immer
weiter rheins und der sucht die ganze
zeit immer weiter in das bild rein als
als wenn wir durch eigene galaxie gerade
durch fliegen wir muss sich halt
zwischendurch mal schnitte setzen weil
ich erstens nicht möchte dass ihr so
riesige pausen drin hat wo ich luft
holen muss und zweitens möchte ich nicht
dass dieses video hier
okay das war ganz komisch weil ich
dachte ich muss mich weiter auf den
punkt konzentrieren aber jetzt gehen wir
wieder hier rein und sind wieder hier in
ihr gerät sieht aus wie sieht aus wie so
eine blume ich habe gerade ehrlich
gesagt so ein kleines schlechtes
gewissen mehr oder weniger weil ich in
diesem video bisher so unfassbar wenig
schneide
viele von euch sagen wer tatsächlich
immer luca du schneidest zu viel in den
videos wirklich dass wenn man sachen
einfach durchlaufen aber bei so einer
art video ist es tatsächlich sinnvoll
wenn ich jetzt nicht irgendwie groß
schneide von wegen einblendungen
dazwischen und run zoomen auf meine fans
kämen sondern dass wir uns wirklich nur
auf das konzentrieren was wir hier
gerade vor uns sehen und das ist gerade
wirklich echt krass ich weiß auch nicht
was das ziel von diesem video ist ich
glaube das ist auch so ein juwel forget
your name video ich habe jetzt schon
vergessen wie der titel ist okay
vielleicht scheint es doch was zu
bewirken das ganze geht glaube ich noch
eine minute und jetzt gerade ist es bei
mir auf jeden fall schon so dass es
echte ordentlich mit den augen gerade
rumspielt es jetzt gerade ein bisschen
langsamer und geht jetzt wieder rein das
finde ich so ein bisschen verwirrend
dass er dann nicht in dieses in diesem
schwarzen kreis geht recht sondern jetzt
wieder da irgendwo an den rand das ist
eine ganz ganz komische animation alter
das ist das sieht richtig oh mein gott
und jetzt fahren wir da und auch ein
alter mir wird wieder ein bisschen
schlecht muss ich ehrlich gesagt sagen
also das ist
ich bin gespannt wenn ich hier gleich
weg schau ich habe gerade gesehen wir
haben jetzt noch genau eine minute die
wir hierauf reagieren werden dh wir
fallen jetzt wieder in ein weiteres
regenbogen loch rein ich bin wirklich
gespannt ob hier noch etwas passieren
wird mit den augen also wenn wir
weggucken das irgendwie sich eine
pflanze bewegt oder irgendwas was drum
herum steht weil es hier ja wie bereits
gesagt nicht so ist dass wir irgendwas
haben was sich im kreis dreht und dann
irgendeine struktur beinhaltet sondern
hier ist es wirklich so ergeht auch
jetzt nicht links in den kreis rhein
sondern geht ihr wieder an die seite
irgendwie irgendwas pinkls also hier bin
ich echt gespannt was das für einen
einfluss auf unsere augen haben wird wir
gehen hier wieder weiterhin gegen den
trend ist weder zwischenzeitlich immer
schneller und dann wird es wieder
langsamer also
alter ich weiß nicht ob es bei euch noch
wird aber man musste sich gerade als es
bei mir noch bewegt hat ich musste mich
auf einen punkt fokussieren
beziehungsweise konzentrieren und dieser
punkt ist immer kleiner geworden wisst
ihr was ich meine
das hört sich total bescheuert an falls
jemand genau zu dieser stelle des videos
gerade gesprungen sein sollte und sich
jetzt einfach nur denkt hey was labert
der dafür schwachsinn aber ich glaube
das kam so ein bisschen dadurch dass wir
immer weiter hinein bild rein geflogen
sind und dann wenn ich mir was das erst
mal absolut keinen sinn aber wir machen
weiter mit dem dritten video dieses
video tatsächlich auf den titel das
video we made you forget your name also
einfach wirklich wie bereits gesagt in
die mitte des screen schauen versuchen
nicht zu blinzeln klar wenn man ab und
zu mal blinzeln muss dann einfach nicht
blinzeln gehe auf jeden fall ab und zu
müsste ja blinzeln ist ja schon
schädlich für die augen aber sonst
wirklich ganz weit in die mitte des
screen scraping als ehrlich
mir wird jetzt gerade auch schon wie ein
bisschen sperrig und mich sieht es
gerade wirklich so aus als wenn das so
säbelzahn blätter sind oder so
kreissägen die von der seite irgendwie
rein kommen es ist eine ganz ganz
komische situation hier gerade wenn ich
da rein schauen
für mich wird es auch das in der mitte
wird für mich gerade immer kleiner und
weiß nicht ob es wirklich immer kleiner
wird oder ob sich meine augen das
einbilden aber für mich ist mittlerweile
schon
echt ziemlich klein ich glaube dass das
hier tatsächlich wieder ein video sein
wird wo wir werden wir hier auch gleich
die 34 minuten reagiert haben dass wenn
wir woanders hin schauen dass wir wieder
komplette crazy sachen sehen werden also
irgendwie das irgendwie was sich dreht
und so weiter und so fort also macht auf
jeden fall noch weiter mit dass jetzt
das letzte video auf dass wir reagieren
werden wir werden uns das noch drei
minuten anschauen und dann werden wir
wieder unsere blicke auf irgendetwas
anderes hier im zimmer richten also bei
mir beispielsweise auf meine pflanze im
hintergrund oder auf meinem regal oder
irgendwie sowas und ihr könnt dann ja
auch wenn ihr zuhause seit gerade
irgendwie auf eure band gucken glaube
ich glaub auf eine wand guckt auf eine
leere wand gucken ist am krassesten wenn
man so was macht ich will am liebsten
mich jetzt schon oben drehen und mir
irgendwas anschauen aber ich will dem
ganzen noch diesen krasseren effekt
geben weil natürlich je länger man jetzt
dort in die mitte des screens schaut
desto besser ist dann die illusion
nachher
ich weiß nicht warum diese video rein
heißen das video we made you forget your
name weil der seinen namen da vergisst
er ist wirklich einfach nur dumm damit
hat dann glaube ich das video nichts zu
tun sondern einfach mit dem intelligenz
quotient und den gehirnzellen der
zuschauenden personen
aber ich bin auf jeden fall gespannt was
passiert wenn ich mir gleich irgendwas
anschaue hier im raum
ich habe ehrlich gesagt auch ein
bisschen angst davor wenn ich mich dann
gucke dass sie nicht von beiden falle
die sache ist dass es bei diesem video
glaube ich nur um diese eine animation
hier geht also ich wollte mir die videos
natürlich auch nicht vorher schon
angucken einfach weil mir nicht diese
reaktion auf diese animation vorweg zu
nehmen ich weiß ich hab das ganze schon
mal vor eineinhalb zwei jahren gemacht
aber da war es ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen anders weil ich halt
zwischendurch noch mit der kamera
gespielt habe ich habe in die kamera
reingeschaut ich habe ein paar witze
erzählen ich habe alter
gerade es ganz schlimm
gerade ist ganz schön ich glaube es so
ich glaube ich musste mich langsamer
wegdrehen davon aber ich will einfach
den optimal krassesten effekt irgendwie
bewirkten bei meinen augen was irgendwie
klar geht deswegen meine damen und
herren bei mir ist es mittlerweile
wirklich so dass mir ein bisschen
schwummrig wird also wir schauen weg vom
screen in 321
online platzhalter das ist nicht wahr
alter ich schaue an die scheiß wand und
die band dreht sich
dies weil ivan mega willst mich
verarschen alter
hier heißt sich noch mal anders hätte
würde das heutige video ist allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben zuschauer ganz
ganz ganz ganz viele von euch haben wir
unter meinen letztes video was ich
hierzu gemacht haben die kommentare
geschrieben luca bitte du hättest nicht
so viel schneiden dürfen macht das doch
einfach so dass wir das gemeinsam mit
dem machen können dass es einfach uncut
so ein bisschen durchlaufen ich hab
natürlich dennoch ein paar schnitte
gesetzt einfacher damit ihnen nicht
pausen mitkriegt wo ich gerade luft
holen muss uns weiter und so fort ich
hoffe allerdings dass ihr das ganze vor
allem jetzt bei der letzten animation
mit mir zusammen machen konnte schreibt
immerhin die kommentare was mit euren
augen danach passiert ist also was habt
ihr angeschaut was habt ihr dann gesehen
bei mir war so ich habe als allererstes
auf meine pflanze da geschaut und die
pflanze hat sich verdammt noch mal im
kreis gedreht danach habe ich an die
wand geschaut da saß ein bisschen sollte
würde die band gerade schmelzen und
meine smiley kissen alter das war das
ist so schon komisch wenn man daran
guckt man die zu 50 kisten schwarz-weiß
angeordnet aber das war echt auch
komplett crazy das t shirt das ich
gerade hier an habe ist teil der neuen
kollektion die am 16
rauskommen darüber werde ich demnächst
am barren gesondertes video hochladen
aber ich würde mich auf jeden fall
freuen wenn ihr euch den ersten sechst
schon mal eintragen würde den kalender
und jetzt meine damen und herren wenn es
euch gefallen hat und ich das ganze noch
mal machen soll dann lasst ein like da
und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]